welcome back to glam unfiltered host by
me josh smith and today
we are joined by the divine lucy hale
[Music]
i feel your energy all the way in
california
how are you doing babe i
every day i'm like is this real is this
all really happening
you know what that being said i'm fine
i'm good i'm hanging in there
trying to stay busy trying to stay
creative you know we're all going a
little stir crazy and california's
back on lockdown but uh but i'm good
it's almost like the mental
hangover from what has happened over the
last four months has been
so extreme
it's long have you managed it in your
own mind
you know i because i'm a person who
overthinks
everything and like i'm always planning
10 steps ahead like my biggest challenge
was
not having a panic attack every 30
minutes no it was really just like
the time actually was good because i
rarely
allow myself to like slow down enough to
like sit with myself so it was good i
got some alone time
did some like necessary self-work um but
i hear you i feel like we're all kind of
traumatized by this year
but but i'm coming out of it okay yeah
what kind of self-worth have you been
doing i find it so intriguing because
everyone's been doing it
i think for me i realized i put so much
of my identity
in what i do and how productive i am
so when that's stripped away i was like
oh my god
like who them and i realized like
yes i love my job and i love i love
being creative and i love getting to do
all these opportunities but that doesn't
make up who i
am like lucy stands alone without x y
and z
so i think just like really doing things
that i've always wanted to do that don't
get any feedback like just like
i wanted to learn um like to paint or to
cross stitch and so i started all these
little hobbies that became like passion
hobbies
yeah and they actually like brought me
so much joy and i was like it's so nice
to do something where
i don't need validation or i don't need
like i don't have to get feedback from
anything i started meditating
which was new how is that for you
because i just don't think i could ever
be the person to meditate
um it's hard it's i started i truly
started off with two minutes
and now i can like kind of get to 30
minutes um but it's nice it's kind of
nice to kick start your day
that way um i don't every day i didn't
today i didn't yesterday but
i try i'm trying the thing you're saying
about
your how much your identity is attached
to what you do
it's so mad how we've been almost
conditioned into thinking that
our personalities and i and almost like
our self-worth is so built into our jobs
right
right i read something the other day
what did i post it said um your day
shouldn't be measured by your
productivity
your day should be measured by how
present you are and i was like that's so
true we should live every day like that
but we are kind of conditioned that like
have to hustle hustle hustle work work
work
and if we take a day off we're lazy
which is just ridiculous i think that
like if anything this time
has allowed most of us to relax and
allow ourselves to relax it's so
important to recharge because
i think we all realize we're all just
exhausted
like irritable and anxious because we're
tired that being said i'm really ready
to get back to work
i'm over sitting around but um but it
has been a good lesson
i think for all of us and luckily for
all of us in uk kate keane is coming
to bbc i play yes it is
katie hey i
love you but fashion emergency i love it
i think it's so great and what i love
about it is this
very determined young woman who is out
there
she's following those dreams she's gonna
get those dreams
but for you you've had to personally go
out there
follow your own dreams you've had to
sacrifice probably quite a lot of things
along the way
for you what kind of sacrifices have you
had to make in the pursuit
of your dreams there are so many
parallels between katie's story and my
real life story because i moved late
when i was 15. so like
i i was homeschooled all through high
school i never went to
never step foot in a real high school um
so i sacrificed a lot of
like what you call normal growing up
whatever that is because i did grow up
very fast like i started working at 16
supporting myself at 17
like lived on my own at 18 like
everything was just kind of
um quick so um i didn't realize how much
i had sacrificed
being a kid until like i'm now 31 i was
like oh i kind of missed out on some
things but
no regrets like i love where i'm at it's
worth it you know it's definitely worth
it i've worked
i've worked hard and thank god it paid
off because i didn't have a backup plan
i really didn't so many people always
see this like surface level of success
don't they they see that
there's the opportunities where people
have said yes to you right like
because that that's what brings you to
the screens right and there's
as katie gets this there's so many no's
along the way as well
like what do you think is a a no that
you've received that's actually become a
very
positive thing for you in retrospect
years ago before pretty little liars i
did a show called privileged it was on
the cw
um it got cancelled it was a no
but those producers were like we like
lucy we like her let's do something with
her
they ended up casting me in pretty
little liars so it's like situations
that don't always go your way
lead you to where you're supposed to be
and i'm such a firm believer that like
if you trust the universe it's gonna
take you where you're supposed to be
you just have to like listen to your gut
listen to your intuition and like never
ever
ever ever give up like never just don't
take no for an answer a lot of people
aren't caught up for this
for this industry because it is 99
rejection truly it all the time like i
still get
horrible feedback all the time but it's
just a matter of
you know just like shifting that like
mindset a little bit and making it a
positive for you because
you dictate your future you are writing
your own story
um and you just have to remember that
like the steering wheel is in your hands
like you control
you can control your future so yeah it's
a mindset thing
there is still like and especially in
this show because i was thinking about
this when you the only
scene where you go and see the boss and
she's like oh we only used to employ
single girls we only used to do this and
we used to do that
there's still so much labeling that is
attached to women in our society like
if you're ambitious that's seen as a
negative thing if you're like this it
seemed like a negative thing and there's
this labeling process a it has to start
the b it's all going on
i deserve this promotion katie you might
not look like it but you're a gutter
girl
and that is never gonna change and
the lighting down here is doing nothing
for you what kind of
labels have you had to kind of like
rip off and get rid of and what kind of
like everyday sexism have you had to
come up against in that sense
i've always been very polite and very
and a lot of people take that as
weakness
or like as naive and that's not it at
all
um so i've had to like really learn to
be polite but also stay in my ground so
like being a nice person who doesn't
take
and so still sometimes i'm like very
worried that if i speak my mind that
i'll be like labeled a [ __ ] or like too
much
but that's so silly because why
like we should be able to speak our
minds but do it in a way that
um that is gracious you know and so
that's that's sort of been like my whole
thing is um
learning to say no and like set
boundaries for myself because
i by nature i'm just like a people
pleaser so like i want to make everyone
happy
but that's not sustainable so i've
really learned
to only do the things that i really want
to do and it feels so nice to be at a
point in my life and in my career where
i can be like
i don't want to do that role i don't
want to do that interview i do want to
do that interview
hence why i'm speaking to you i wanted
to do this um and i wanted to do katy
keem
because then you just feel better about
yourself if you're always doing things
for people that you don't want to do
like you just feel like crap
it really is you realizing the power of
saying no
is kind of like the greatest gift of all
right and you just feel like the
shackles are
gone and you're like thank god i said no
to that
and now i'm like learning to say no but
not apologizing for it because then i
would say no but i would be like but i'm
so sorry i can't do this
now i'm just like no that doesn't work
for me and i think as well for kate king
she is going on this
journey of self-discovery in so many
different ways in terms of relationships
friendships her identity and so many
facets of her life for you
sitting here today what do you think has
been the greatest turning point
in the discovery of yourself in
understanding yourself
wow i still have moments every day where
i'm like
having you know turning points like i
you know
i told you i'm 31 but i don't think i
like grew up until last year
like i went through some things that
were like okay you're getting yours
together
and we're gonna be an adult now so i
actually just now feel
uh you know like the last year like i
feel settled in my skin and comfortable
with who i am
and and happy with the person i am and
the decisions i'm making
one final question i want to ask you is
if you could sit
the you who was about to go
into your career on a zoom call right
here right now she was sat here
here old me okay i've owed you what
would you want to say to her
oh wow there's a lot of things i would
say
avoid this avoid that person don't do
this but ultimately
i spent so much of my younger years just
worrying about things that didn't matter
whether it be
my body or the way i looked or the way
people perceived me
and i think because of that i lost out
on some really great moments because i
wasn't
present i used i still struggle with
being very present because like i said
i'm always
10 steps ahead which can be good but um
i would just tell myself to really
soak it in and love it and just be
grateful for every single second because
um you don't get that back and i think
that it really is important
it's important to be present um not that
i wasn't but i could have i could have
done a little better but that's okay
live and learn
well babe i think you're doing pretty
damn well now so
keep at it keep being present keep
slaying it and hopefully i speak to you
super soon hopefully in
life and not on a zoom call but would be
lovely
thanks so much it's been so great
speaking to you likewise
you have a good it's evening over there
so have a good night